[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to theories and
Thrones a show where fans can come
together and completely geek out over
Game of Thrones final season I'm Liana
Gyu lair from Entertainment Tonight and
I'm Mike Rizzo from gamespot Game of
Thrones eighth and final season is just
a few days away so today we're gonna be
breaking down a few of our favorite fan
theories I'm so excited and the best
part of theories of Thrones is that we
are currently live right now and we want
to hear from all of you because we know
that the GOG fandom has a lot of
thoughts so start commenting below with
your favorite theories about what you
think is gonna happen in these last six
episodes and Mike and I will be reading
them throughout the show and then a big
cluster at the end we also have an
exclusive interview with the legend
himself author george RR martin he
spills some brand new answers about his
books and also the one story line he
wish I made it into the show but let's
dive into the first theory that we want
to highlight and that is that Jaime will
kill see this is a common theory very
common it's been out there for a long
time but it's also one of my favorites
because I think it's one that makes the
most sense
definitely so the essential kind of
breakdown for this one is all linked to
the flashback at the start of season 5
so as a kid Cersei visited a woods which
named Maggie the Frog who told her
things like she would have three kids
and the king would have 20 and her kids
would wear golden shrouds and golden
crowns right ie they would be dead so
all that was in the show and so far all
of her prophecies have come true yeah
but in the books there was actually more
to that scene maggie also predicted that
seriously would die at the hands of
someone called the valonqar which is
high Valyrian for little brother so in
the books that kind of fueled her hatred
of her younger brother Tyrion for like
their entire lives
um now obviously in the show she has
plenty of motivation for hating Tyrion
including believing that he killed her
son King Joffrey yeah it makes sense
that they you know would feel like they
could cut that yeah
but the prophecy might have other
meanings for example although Cersei
Jamie are twins everybody knows he was
actually born shortly after her so he's
our little brother right technically
he's also her little brothers Jamie
killing Cersei could fulfill this
prophecy then again the last time we saw
him he was like riding as far in the
other direction
yeah and ultimately if Cersei really is
pregnant yeah well there's the theory
that she'll die in childbirth the new
baby would be a little brother to her
other children which would make it the
valonqar but as maggie predicted that
Cersei would only have three kids I'm
thinking this pregnancy will probably
not end well for her if it's even real
in the first place because truly I do
not believe a word she said yeah I don't
buy it I don't understand like how
Tyrion is like it seems like she's
putting on an act and we don't buy it
tell us in the comments right now though
do you think she's really pregnant do
you think Jaime will kill Cersei tell us
all your thoughts but right now Mike I
want to talk to you because you are a
die-hard Game of Thrones book fan and I
know you were let's say bummed that this
one huge storyline has been missing from
the show kick us off with your theory
about the other Aegon Targaryen right
the other Aegon Targaryen because Jon
Snow's real name is Aegon Targaryen is
we found out last season but so I guess
this is a book spoiler but if you
haven't read the books just they're like
years go read them anyway there's
another Aegon Targaryen in the books
this one is allegedly the true born son
of Rhaegar Targaryen who is Danny's
brother and Elia Martell the story goes
when the Baratheon's and Starks and
Lannisters rebelled against the Mad King
Aerys which is before long before the
show started this is history Tywin
Lannister had the mountain who we all
know hunt down and kill Elia Martell and
her kids to ensure there would be no
more Tigers left after era's head rape
and Rhaegar died yeah this is what the
red Viper was so pissed about in season
four as we all
and then the head explode yeah we were
all traumatized together so so the
corpses that the mountain returned with
were unrecognizable because he's such a
Butthead
he smashed their heads against a wall
you know famously so everybody just
assumed that it was the right kids the
books eventually revealed this plot
between Varys and Illyrio and Ray gars
friend Jon connington and a mercenary
band called the golden company so
supposedly baby Aegon was switched with
another kid before the mountain did his
dirty deed and the real egg on has been
kind of growing up in Essos with the
golden company yeah and this relates
like the golden company has its own
history in the books the golden company
was founded by a faction of rebel
Targaryen bastards called the black
fires there were Wars they rebelled
against Targaryen rule like multiple
times and they're dedicated to seeing
their family returned to the Iron Throne
it's like a whole mess in the books that
the show hasn't really touched on but
importantly this is the golden company
Cersei in at the end of season 7 hired
the golden company she sent you're on
with the iron fleet to pick them up in
Essos bring them back to Westeros to
help defend her throne if their story in
the in the show has anything to do with
their story in the books that's probably
not going to end well for her I know
that it will and and it's kind of
interesting because I feel like you were
saying that in the books at the time
Danny was kind of dealing with the
Marines stuff when all this was
happening so the timelines are all
completely off right the timeline is is
it doesn't work in the show the way that
it did in the books like but by the time
that Aegon is introduced in the books
Dany is still ruling Marines she's still
doing all that stuff and Aegon is like
he's late he's the first Targaryen to
make it back to Westeros in the books
he's like making alliances taking
castles it's awesome frankly so you know
but with the golden company finally
being introduced in season 8 could some
version of their they are could some
version of the storylines still have
been yeah we saw that in the trailer one
of the most recent trailer for season 8
that is the golden company that is Harry
Strickland who I guess is their there
he's a character from the books and he's
there
in the show I really hope that they do
some version of the golden company
storyline for the books otherwise
they're just a bunch of dummies with a
fancy name and allegedly elephants yeah
but fair enough um I love this theory
but with only six episodes to go I'd be
really shocked if the writers try to
squeeze in this twist into there it just
seems like too much too fast what do you
guys think do you think we need to see
Aegon Targaryen tell us in the comments
there's one more theory that we wanted
to chat about and it's centered on the
night king this theory bear with me is
that maybe the night king not such a bad
guy this series has been around for a
long time in one form or another
basically the idea is that the idea of
the night King as like this classical
fantasy like Dark Lord style evil
villain it just doesn't fit with like
the message and the themes of this
series exactly and one version of this
really great theory was articulated
really well in a reddit post from a few
years ago that we will post to a link
after this live and the post cites a
2011 interview with george RR martin
where he says that although he admires
Tolkien and gives him credit for
basically creating the modern fantasy
the the tropes of good versus evil and
that good guys will triumph over bad
guys and fantasy quote have become kind
of a cartoon and he wants to do
something different yeah so if the
knight king isn't evil because he wants
to do something different than just you
know classic good versus evil what is
the night king um there's a lot of
theories about this we saw the White
Walkers creation in a flashback with
bran in the show which is a moment that
we still haven't seen in the books
that's show only yeah but maybe the
children in the forest of the real bad
guys maybe the White Walkers are just
like they're ponds or they're
misunderstood somehow maybe as some
people think the night king used to be
bran and there's some time-travel stuff
involved and he has more complicated
reasons for working south honestly
though I'm so sick of this
good night King Theory is Brant like I'm
sorry it's a bad eye
everyone's just like latched on to it
and I I'm just tired of it it's terrible
maybe as that reddit post predicts
humans are the real villains of the
story and the White Walkers are marching
south to prevent Danny for him
destroying the whole world with fire and
blood like she keeps threatening yeah
that seems to be like her biggest
instinct whenever something is going
wrong she's like well I'll just burn it
down your car's it's true yeah so who
knows what's gonna happen in season
eight one way or another we're going to
get an answer that question though and
I'm gonna be very disappointed if it's
just you know nope the White Walkers are
evil and you overthought this there's
nothing else to it
but speaking of being disappointed we're
still waiting on our last two books from
the ruler of the realm mr. George RR
Martin's so when I caught up with him at
the Game of Thrones premiere last week I
asked him for an update plus I tried to
coax a few more secrets out of him take
a look so many storylines that they've
been able to fit into the show but of
course not as many as that we're in the
books
what is one storyline from the books
that you would have loved to have seen
making its way into the show Lady
Stoneheart that's certainly the book I'm
writing now that's an important thread
but as you say there's so much there
even with a novel of ordinary size when
you adapt it for television the film it
usually involves cutting and simplifying
and my books are not books of ordinary
length I mean even Game of Thrones which
is actually the smallest of them is like
four regular novels so there was a lot
to do if we'd included everything in the
books we'd still be on season 1 it would
have been an 8 year long season 1
they're hard choices sometimes but
that's the business book update how are
you doing with the writing do you have a
date for us I have no date I've given up
giving dates because I give one and then
I miss it and everybody gets mad it'll
be done when it's done it's been going
very well lately so knock wood finale of
Game of Thrones will this necessarily be
the same ending that is gonna be in your
books as well well I'll have to see
won't we
I don't want to spoil my books or the
show so watch both and then read the
book and you decide I'm still annoyed I
understand
saying there obviously there's an
overwhelming amount of source material
but I still would have loved to see
Catalans dark again that moment in the
epilogue of storm swords was was one of
my favorite reveals in the entire series
I still remember the first time I read
it I was in college and I read the
epilogue and I literally threw my book
across the room because it was just like
what am i reading you know what Mike
maybe she'll still randomly pop up who
knows maybe she's the real reason why
aria looks so freakin terrified as she's
running through the halls of Winterfell
and this is a trailer yeah I know you're
so disappointed lately I'm trying to
give you something to hold on to we'll
see now we want to go through some of so
we've got some great ones keep sending
men right now guys we have Daniela and
she says I think I'm the only one in the
fandom that ships Sansa Stark and Tyrion
Lannister a romantic couple and who also
wants to see both Denarius and Jon as
the king and queen of the Seven Kingdoms
Daniela I don't think you're wrong
I think that both Mike and I agree that
we would love to see Danny and Jon Co
rule yeah that would be that I mean I
don't think it's gonna happen
yes that's be too happy it's my perfect
ending is the two of them finding out
they're related ruling to marry they're
brother and sister yeah all the time -
nephew it's like not as bad yeah that
would be my as far as Tyrion and Sansa
though I don't know what's gonna happen
there but Sansa is at Winterfell and
Tyrion is on his way there yeah with Jon
and Danny's haven't seen each other
since the purple wedding right since she
bailed right after Joffrey got killed
they haven't dared there hasn't been a
reunion between them since then so I'm
very excited to see if that happens i I
kind of just always want Sansa to just
be like single like she needs a minute
yeah she's had a rough time that's true
um Isis says Sansa deserves to be Queen
deserves but it would be cool I think
Arya would be a great Queen but that's
just me is Arya wearing Sansa's face oh
nice
she's right here with it last season so
who knows next one Alicia I think Arya
will kill Cersei as Jaime would that
technically fulfill that prophecy
probably not but it Arya has set a
president in recent seasons of putting
on other people's faces and then killing
people knocking people off her list and
that list is getting really short it is
and we know that the most prominent name
on it currently is still Cersei as she
keeps reminding us she said it a bunch
our season seven so I don't know do you
think she took the Hound officially off
the list that's a really good question
actually no we haven't heard her whisper
it in a while yeah like I feel like she
wouldn't kill it she had her chance yes
exactly she had her chance she just
robbed him instead Calliope e says I see
the end with Tyrion and Sansa on the
throne Wow okay so Daniella we got your
answer you got the only one they would
be a good I think even-tempered ruling
pair yeah I mean they would do a good
job but like how often in this series do
the people who do the good job the good
ending they they're not the ones who
wind up in charge although John is in
charge you know yeah or he was for a
while in the north Elise until he
relinquished all power because that's
what he likes to do random says the
night king will be killed by John and
Danny together but leading to John's
death I really enjoyed this theory yeah
I truly am thinking that we are not
gonna get to the end of Game of Thrones
without seeing John or Danny die one of
them has got to go and do you think it
will be a sacrifice for the other yeah
it also kind of relates to stuff that we
didn't touch on but but those are high
and the prince that was promised and all
that stuff in the lore of the series you
know azor Ahai beat back the long night
by sacrificing his wife miss Anissa or
whatever yeah so there's there's a lot
of parallels to their story with John
and Danny and there the thought is that
one of them is going to have to
sacrifice the other well and Haibo
actually echoes this thought and says
Jon Snow might die Game of Thrones has a
way of breaking her our hearts here's my
thing they'll come if he already died
would we would our hearts break again
like I
I guess but like I guess I would be more
upset if Danny died just because I don't
see her getting to the end of the Iron
Throne she's worked too hard for it she
deserves it but I just don't see it
happening but if John Doe
I feel like John's already on borrowed
time in my opinion I like we went her at
once yeah I know he's he's back and for
for people who you know put a lot of
stock in the books he's still dead in
the books that you know winds of winter
isn't out so like for him to come back
in the show was like such a huge moment
yeah and if it was just for him to die
later yes my heart would be broken
George sir move tell us tell us what's
gonna happen
what other comments do we have that we
want to highlight right Chris says I
would love to see Jaime Lannister become
king what a fun evolution that would be
from Kingslayer to king right and my
other favorite Jaime theory is that he
will kill the night king because it
would be like a fulfillment his title as
the Kingslayer which is you know like a
derogatory title that's been given to
him because he was a member of the he
was in the Kingsguard and he killed King
Aerys and you know people always call
him King Slayer Oathbreaker etc ever
since then so if he was the one who's
like the ultimate hero who winds up
killing the nigh king maybe he won't
wind up on the throne after that it's
been so fun I know that both of us did a
rewatch of the entire series right
before this but it's so crazy to go back
to season it was a lot to go back to
season one Jaime and be like oh my god I
forgot you were a massive dude he's a
different person Tamara says Danny and
John ruling together will not happen
because that this is Game of Thrones
fair point that's basically what if it's
the ending that we want it's probably
not gonna happen but that's fine you
know I'm looking forward to being
surprised
yeah oh diali oh I'm sorry from seeing
your name wrong but this is amazing
I just want Gendry in Arya romance I
don't care about the rest yeah so this
is another one that that Arya is in
Winterfell and kendrys headed there with
John and Danny you've seen him in the
trailers in the trailer at the forge of
Winterfell probably making dragonglass
weapons they've seen each other in
seasons this is gonna be a season of
Union as much as that that's been true
of
other recent seasons like Starks
reuniting for the first time in years
we're gonna get a ton more of that even
with like all of the secondary yeah all
the living is trying to band together at
this point so do you think aria is out
there looking for love though I don't
think she's ever looking for they always
when you looked back at their first
journey together back when getting new
that she was actually a girl disguised
as a boy they had such a sweet banter
back chemistry they had chemistry back
then it was weird cuz she was really
young she's grown up if she's grown up
now she's learned a lot and I think it's
good just look good growing in that boat
man you can make the USC crew team Arzu
says there's a theory that you're on
Greyjoy is going to kill Denarius I
don't know I feel like that like it's a
interesting theory I haven't heard of
but if that happens like , I'm sure
there's lots of evidence that if you go
back to the books you're on in the show
is kind of a combination of a few
different books characters one of them
being victorian who is like another
brother of Balon and Euron he's like
another of that crew of the Greyjoy's
and you're on has actually sent him to
marine in the books to capture Danny for
year on Victoria and has his own plans
of the books he decides that he's gonna
capture Danny for himself he's gonna you
know do whatever Dragon queen or
whatever I mean that has all yet to play
out my I think for me my main issue with
Joran is that they introduced him much
later in the show that he was in the
books and also he's such a almost
cartoonish version of a villain yeah
he's like he's like a roguish like a
pirate yeah like it's almost like too
much I don't know
I agree I don't I don't love what
they've done with him in the show but if
I feel like if if somebody like him who
kind of was just injured feels like a
newer addition yeah and killed Danny
yeah I don't feel like they we're good
it would be a good payoff that would be
disappointing I agree we we appreciate
your theory but we don't like it they
might have I mean like what we don't
expect you know yeah Taylor has a weird
theory for us yay Taylor the Iron Throne
gets destroyed and Tyrion creates a
democracy in the Senate
I don't feel like this is not weird I
love it yeah I I spoke with Harry Lloyd
recently who he played viscera star Gary
and in season one and he's in next
season of Legion on FX and so I had the
chance to talk with him recently and I
asked him who do you want to see her in
the iron on the Iron Throne this is on
gamespot.com
yeah and he said no one he said he wants
the you know the monarchy to be
abolished and and to see a democracy in
Westeros so I feel like it's not that
weird of a theory Taylor I love that and
while we're reef lugging Emilia Clarke
told me on the carpet for season six I
asked her who do you think deserves or
how do you think want Danny to die yeah
and she said I want her to get so close
to the Iron Throne and just as she's
about to touch it it explodes wildfire
wildfire we're just a couple more
comments you guys have so many great
theories right now ash Crossan says the
night King deserves the Iron Throne he
doesn't let emotions get in the way and
honestly like who's he that's a pretty
long we don't know this is right we
don't know is he a good guy is he a bad
guy maybe he needs
hopefully I really hope you know what
ash I hope you're right I hope you all
right ash thank you so much for
contributing and I think you know what
we're gonna end it right there
thank you all so much for tuning in
today and be sure to join us for
theories and Thrones every Monday
morning at 8 a.m. west coast in 11 a.m.
east coast for the next six weeks yeah
the next six weeks that's all it's left
yeah we're gonna be breaking down every
episode of Game of Thrones after it airs
we're gonna be looking at all your
comments are going to be including all
your thoughts and all the biggest
theories about the final season yeah
basically we just want this to be the
place where you watch the episode you
come back here you freak out with us and
you can always tweet us your thoughts
anytime you'd like thanks again for
watching theories and Thrones and we'll
see you guys on Monday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]